I think we're likely to probably see gay
marriage in California but absolutely
not a constitutional right to gay
marriage in all 50 states hi I'm Matt
Welch for recent TV and I am joined by
our Supreme Court damon root who has
just come back from oral arguments in
the California Proposition 8 hearings
Damon I've heard scuttlebutt so far on
the internet that we might be headed
towards a punt is that consistent with
what you've seen what's going on I mean
basically what you one of the big issues
was standing it is so what happened was
California the government of California
said we're not going to defend prop 8 in
court initially it's this is a voter
initiative so the voters of California
amend the Constitution by ballot to
prohibit gay marriage the government of
California says well we're not going to
defend that we think that's wrong we
think that's that violates equal
protection so then who can defend who is
the standing to defend the law in court
and the California Supreme Court rules
that the backers of the ballot
initiative have the standing Supreme
Court US Supreme Court today at least by
my account the four liberal justices and
probably also Chief Justice Roberts seem
to think that these people do not have
the standing to bring the case which
would send send the ruling back to the
district court levels which could mean
one of basically two things that we have
gay marriage in California but nowhere
else or the ruling is limited just to
the to same-sex couples that brought the
case so they could have marriages but no
one else I so I think we're likely to
probably see gay marriage in California
but absolutely not a constitutional
right to gay marriage in all 50 states
now Justice Kennedy expressed open kind
of uncertainty about like even talking
about the case you felt like it gone too
far talk about that little well Kennedy
so you know Kennedy is the author of the
Supreme Court's two big pro-gay rights
decisions and particularly Lawrence
versus Texas which struck down Texas's
ban on on sodomy and so he's seen as an
a real ally of the gay rights movement
however in this case he said today he
said you know there's the courts
cantering into uncharted waters was one
of his quotes but he also said and I
think maybe more importantly was that
why did we even take this case this
doesn't he seem to not want to have
anything to do with it and not want to
basically join a majority on either
ruling on the constitutional merits and
so that that could we could have a very
complicated decision where you have you
know five to six justices saying that
there's no standing to rule on the case
Kennedy saying we shouldn't have heard
it to begin with so this is it's
definitely not any kind of a slam dunk
you know there's a right to gay marriage
and tomorrow we're hearing the Defense
of Marriage Act constitutionality which
is a different question but they'll be
lumped together do you see the court
kind of looking for a political way out
so as not to stick their necks out too
far or are they responding to public
opinion which is shifting very fast on
this question well there was a lot of
talk about shifting public opinion and
basically every lawyer brought it up
multiple justices brought it up I mean
so they're thinking about this they're
weighing this and that's one of the
arguments lido made this argument
Roberts been this argument which is that
why not let the people decide voters are
making their minds up on this issue why
should the court step in so there's sort
of a classic argument about judicial
restraint and deference let the sort of
voters decide and so that was an
argument made today in the Defense of
Marriage Act case the sort of a you know
a deference argument gets kind of turned
on its head because there you have
Congress acting and perhaps overstepping
its bounds and and interfering with the
decisions that voters in the state level
have made by legalizing same-sex
marriage so you've got this these this
there's definitely a concern and an
interest in what that what the people
are doing and letting people have their
way now this is divided this these cases
have divided libertarians in addition to
Americans trying to wrestle the relative
importance of allowing States to be
laboratories with democracy or
oppression as the case may be and and
trying to restrain government these
kinds of types of things could a
kickback on standing levels for the prop
8 case coupled with a ruling that DOMA
is unconstitutional is that some kind of
libertarian almost Christmas or is that
what would that combination of rulings
look like well you know so the
libertarian division is is basically
that does federalism mean a state can
ban gay marriage or or does order
libertarians say that the Fourteenth
Amendment means that gay marriage is
unconstitutional because it violates
equal protection so assuming that the
state should be able to sort this out
for themselves a calm
nation of limiting Congress's power
under the Defense of Marriage Act plus
kicking it back and letting gay marriage
happen on the state by state level I
mean that would be the sort of a guess
abroad Federalists piece by piece Ann's
but libertarians weighed in actually on
the prop 8 side hoping to get it struck
down yeah that's correct you know
leading libertarian organizations and
scholars you know favor I mean there are
other libertarians are against we're
against striking down prop eight but i
think it's generally safe to say that
libertarian the league libertarian legal
position was that Prop 8 is
unconstitutional okay you're a betting
man you got ten bucks what are you
betting on for the prop 8 case I would
say I think we're going to see a ruling
that they doubt that the prop 8 backers
do not have standing I could see the
Chief Justice joining with the four
liberals on that and that would
effectively send it back to the states I
think it will be limited to California
so we'll we'll see gay marriage in
California but but that's as far as it
goes that's great for reason TV I'm Matt
Welch with Damon route thank you very
much